[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about what it was like an
extended play of your normal one yeah
that's a new one
today's a special edition bought the
record because we're just gonna spend
the whole time trying to get Steve Fire
is take BuzzFeed employees and bring
them in to JK news was alive is he is
the inventor of this cheap [ __ ] versus
this is why people are spending five
grand for pizza on YouTube right now is
actually true five thousand are Pizza
versus a 20-hour Pizza right like that
slows the first video you guys did it
was three dollars sushi versus two
hundred dollars sushi which is a good
reason into that video right yeah cuz
you could make two hundred back like
pretty easy with views you know I will
say this though that thank God for your
thing because now I don't have to find
out for myself
don't want to spend five hundred bucks
do makeup people we're doing it with
dupes to like beauty gurus got in on
that like this $500 highlighter or this
two-dollar highlighter do i watch this
channel called the wolf pit and this guy
he just tried it all her tree frozen
food and he always can't believe that it
sucks dude I was gonna do like a cooking
dollar dollars for cooking thing I
wanted to make a dinner out of just
dollar from not having dinner at your
house yeah yeah I mean for that I love
white trash food dude I don't I grew up
on that stuff hey you know what's
interesting I found out another brand
that's gonna ignore me hot pockets
you just found them well I've been
trying to get them to talk to me they're
not having it because you love hot
pockets genuinely my [ __ ] love heart
I [ __ ] love that dude the ham and
cheese one ham and cheese pepperoni the
chicken alfredo won the Milly cheese
when I loved all that [ __ ] you know we
used to eat hot pockets when we were
younger but I found out like after so
many months that I had been eating a
beef hot pocket I thought they were
mushrooms cuz that's the consistency of
pretty true that's for sure you have a
question iswhy watch JK news yeah you
guys spent like half the show begging
for sponsors anybody actually not
begging well not to charities that
doesn't need to beg bet she don't need
to back [ __ ] sponsors on my personal
Channel than I do on JK news I get no
sponsors anytime literally and like the
antithesis to people wanting to like
support them right
I don't understand why cuz I have great
engagement maybe it's because I post
news of myself but that might be the key
you need to find like a lingerie brand
or something that fits the the nudity
like I drink a lot and alcohol likes to
sponsor me see I'm trying to get a hair
care brand but I think that they're all
afraid to like we don't want your hair
to be the vision of our couple I just
want a [ __ ] hair care thing I want
something anything well I do get Brad's
but then psych it's not the ones I want
no but then you know it's like come on
it is you're like I want some point you
get DiGiorno you get toyou DiGiorno I
feel [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh that that's
why
I'm telling you have you noticed they
don't want people they want like like
skinny ass people to promote David's
been losing lots of weight lost more
weight things like FC yeah so he could
pretend that it was because of dis or
not so stupid but they don't want to lie
either this is how stupid you [ __ ]
major brands alright to sponsor me this
is how [ __ ] this out dumb General
Mills is okay watch me please stupid you
are I will get Jake a new sponsorship
this is granny buddies burning with me
you guys actually [ __ ] think people
give a [ __ ] about your cereal somebody
curses that's how [ __ ] dumb you are
everybody eats cereal you [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] and if it's good cereal you know
what we do we try your lucky charm would
[Laughter]
[ __ ] yeah why didn't you grow up
Sacramento California okay that's why
why what's up I'm from the Midwest in
Ohio you know it's a very more of a
vanilla country cussing is less of a
thing what yeah no my old family's like
southern people and they swear like they
don't you know they don't your dad gets
my mom your dad gets mad if I say [ __ ]
by at nine eighty that's my current dad
okay that's not calm down father you
don't know my father
oh my father that raised me he's like
doing his penance fruit yes exactly you
know he's a grandfather now so he feels
like he can let go no my old man swears
like me wouldn't believe like McDonald's
things like that is pristine [ __ ]
brand it's like your [ __ ] McDonald's
know who you are [ __ ] McDonald I don't
need to win you over maybe that's the
thing I was in a McDonald's commercial
for the ultimate McDonald's commercial a
guy in a dark room he's only lit by the
screen of his computer and he's watching
loose change the 9/11 documentary while
eating McDonald
the perfect person and the clock reads
201 a.m. yeah and it's all right give me
a break that's where it is Steve about
making that commercial come up I want
some real McDonald [ __ ] like I want a
couple arguing in a drive-thru and while
they're like getting food and then after
they eat they feel like they're cool
you're like but at that yeah great we've
done with commercial idea it's where you
[ __ ] say you're gonna go get
mcdonalds and your girlfriend's like I
don't need anything and you come back
and she's like let me have some your
[ __ ] that's the truest [ __ ] and it's
like now you can get two for one or
whatever see that's good you [ __ ] oh
yeah we're trying to get applied for
busting well I mean I don't I don't know
we I work at BuzzFeed we do things there
I made a show are you gonna make one of
those while of BuzzFeed video sooner
here's my actual opinion on that I think
it's I don't think it's kind of low to
make those videos yeah
well I mean if it was so bad do pretty
well I wouldn't see like okay so if it
was so bad right why are there so many
people that are sticking with that's
okay yeah that's the thing so but the
thing is when these people who made
those videos oh my god I can't wait I'm
saying this a camera go ahead
when they tread carefully when they work
at BuzzFeed they sign a paper that said
I'm going to not own any of this content
so it's not like they didn't know what
they were getting themselves into but
it's crazy that they'll complain about
after work right so to me like I don't
own it I said it's not like JK
we're crazier there's people don't know
we just start doing things and projects
together and then it's like that's it
it's so loose but I heard I heard that
it was more like they weren't allowed to
do their own projects like it's like
some BuzzFeed people thought I know that
laugh they're like the buzz he was
getting mad that they were working on
their own channel
yeah
at some point in the early days that was
less less okay I mean I'm here now with
you guys are like they've loosened like
any time I've asked for permission or
anything you know I've collaborated with
so many different people and they're
cool with it do you think because of
what happened they kind of took a look
at themselves and said it was kind of
like thanks to them now there's more
freedom and there's just more maybe yeah
he doesn't believe that it's really I
can see you don't believe that which is
fine by the way
what know that that day trailblaze for
that because I don't think that either I
don't think that they trailblaze I've
dealt with company drama and I've dealt
with that stuff and I always think like
it's so [ __ ] up to air out that [ __ ]
to the public right like he said they
know what they signed up it's like
someone that doesn't make that surprised
later on after they reap the benefits of
the situation then they [ __ ] about the
circumstances that they already knew
because we had that but people do that
all the time yes they do it's like like
even not BuzzFeed people like
celebrities will be like oh they didn't
you know they didn't treat me nice on
this movie or whatever you know well
that's because they know they can use it
to build the tension for themselves
because now you just have to try people
in the court of public opinion
you know you sign that contract you're
fully aware because what I would do is
try to deal with the company directly
and then I'll say hey I want to talk
about this publicly well a
representative of your company come and
we could have this discussion raw and I
think that would be such a better
learning experience for everyone
versus one person giving their side of
the story and then that's it now the
other side well just think about it well
let's not even do that a lot of
companies have especially an
entertainment because BuzzFeed is an
entertainment company no compete cause
it's like that's that's very [ __ ]
common but you can't work for a company
reap all the [ __ ] benefits and then
you develop a competing company next to
theirs it doesn't [ __ ] work that way
dude that's common [ __ ] it's in every
industry right you love cooks who come
up with dishes for restaurants and then
the restaurant owns a dish they don't
own the dish anymore but that's just how
it is like you have the opportunity to
work with people honestly like the
reason I'm I love is because the people
I work with
right like my
smart co-producers I would never have
met them if it weren't for BuzzFeed so
they created an environment where I was
able to find people that I love for me
like how I see that is this is like you
work for a restaurant and then you take
their ingredients and you're cooking and
selling their food to somebody else dude
it's like the it it's like the humble
Italian chef who designed Pizza Hut
cheesy pizza bites or the stuff press he
doesn't get to keep the recipe okay that
belongs to pizza audience was a game
change according to be cheesy bites you
know he's proud of it but he knows thank
you yeah that's like that's like an
architect that joins a firm and then his
design is like on a [ __ ] billion
dollar building and he only gets paid
whatever salary and he's like I didn't
get a piece of that but it's like yeah
you're paid that's what an employee is
though you exchange your I guess like
ability to yeah you have have equity or
intellectual property in exchange for
security like the companies putting up
money first and they're investing into
you yeah in hopes that you do benefit
the company in a way where it pays off
so it's a fair exchange in my opinion
because I could see it from both sides
and if you did want to take the whole
pie then you should have went into
business for yourself exactly but you
couldn't do it so somebody else's
resources for it and then you're
bitching about it after that doesn't
make any sense to me so after your
contract ends quit and then go somewhere
else
no I don't say that anymore because
people people got sad oh you you change
for the people you let the comments get
you have to get with the time
yeah wow you sold out David let me let
me correct myself I did say it last week
but exactly change it is often as I used
to and plus I'm also thinking about
Stephens brand as well somehow thank you
I need a sponsorships exactly you can't
drag me down you choose to live in your
[ __ ] crud you piece of [ __ ]
can I can I say Stephen cuz everyone
likes to the [ __ ] on BuzzFeed and we've
done a little bit of that but I have but
but I want to say honestly one of my
favorite BuzzFeed videos was when they
got like what do you call it like people
from China to try Panda Express and they
got a bunch of millennial Chinese like
people who grew up in America to try
Panda Express and all the Millennials
like this is not Chinese food are you
kidding me this is not [ __ ] Chinese
food ready
are you joking bro like I'm like man
eating this is crazy a lot more stickler
about their food though they have a lot
of pride in their [ __ ] you know if you
do it Joe tries well yoshino yeah yeah
yeah I think it's because I've had the
Japanese version and the American
version so then your standards change
and I say this like this is truth all
across the board so like some of our
friends who you know had sushi just in
America once they went to Japan and
tried it they came back they're like I
can't eat it
and I let you have it as sugar fish yeah
sugar fish is basically like the normal
sushi in Japan like it's like it's like
the entry level that's like the
drive-through sushi it is it's it's
legitimately conveyor belt sushi that's
level so then they're like I was
wondering why Joe is so pretentious when
it can't a sushi I'm like I'm not it's
just difficult to go back once you tried
and it's cheaper yes and and it's chello
cheaper it's cheap yeah I had six dollar
tour oh yeah wait what about Hiro dreams
it was like [ __ ] 3000
thousand dollars like it's like I think
it's like close to 300 a person yeah but
you even ham I thought it was like 30
it's like no it's like no it's like do
you want to hearing 30 grand
whole year in reservation well my mom
told me that he's he's height because
she's like the locals know of him and in
but he's old news but then but then
because of the Netflix special and like
Obama eating there and all that stuff to
the world he's like a big deal but to
the locals they're they're like oh his
sons are what's really popular now
because they're merging and doing fusion
and stuff that's like next-level
I see so I think a lot of people want to
go there and get the traditional stuff
while the locals they're like that's old
so he's the blink-182 and and his sons
are like the cup upcoming punk rock real
punk rock yeah like the the sons are
like the rock sty just one of the old
men that looks like a turtle to make my
food that's all I know he looks like
it's her that's racist like straight
well he looks I'm sorry he looks like an
Asian turtle I don't think he made eye
contact with the camera one time during
that entire movie I watched that entire
90 minute doc and he the whole time he's
looking at everything else so I contact
is actually rude like I had to learn I
contacts yeah yeah the weirdest of that
contact like for the longest time it's a
combination of two things one is
cultural and the other thing is just
growing up in like a violent environment
you look someone in the eye that's
challenging it's like two pit bulls like
about to fight I'm surprised you're not
a cat person cuz you're not supposed to
like cats and I either yeah you kind of
look a little past them and then they're
like okay I trust you you wanna fight
you want to go yeah I didn't know that I
look at all well that's cuz they love
you now but I can't you don't know her
dog looks you directly in the [ __ ]
windows of your soul daddy [ __ ] love
you though like if it's your dog if it's
your dog that you think well yeah my cat
will look at me and the eyes like
through my soul I do not recommend
people looking into dogs eyes not
strangers dogs though they'll [ __ ] yeah
stranger cats I'm so excited cuz figured
looking people in the eye we get to look
in the eye of crazy people this weekend
because we're going to the can Yule
kitty furball the furball yeah the kid
rescue yeah this weekend so you're
already an already told me yeah so so
Leo everyone dresses up like debutantes
and [ __ ] and they all like and there's
people who bring their cats and they
bring them in like little [ __ ] Louis
Vuitton bags and stuff and they all like
trying to raise money for tech committee
but do you have to buy a ticket to this
yeah well it goes to combinations yes
David you should come it's all the cats
that are owned are like rescue cats or
are they like thousand are again it's
just hilarious cuz they're all cat
ladies and cat people and everyone's
wearing cat ears and cat dresses and
like putting little whiskers on but
they're wearing like a $3,000 dress I
want to dress up as a cat and then not
take my [ __ ] zyrtec I'm highly
allergic like I break out in hives oh my
god just walking through that party with
a drink in your hand and hearing what
everyone's saying it's all mostly like
yeah like I was like I don't need a
sound like I love my cat I caught myself
cos last year I was like oh this place
is getting so trendy cuz before I was
like the youngest person they're like
all older cat ladies and now it's like a
lot of a lot of young young hot little
cat ladies and I'm like [ __ ] you are hot
they are hot it's an open bar though Oh
buddy I just want to dress up like a cat
yeah and then see what happens I feel
like that's the prerequisite of a camper
although they like all kambrose and
Instagram models have to have a cat like
the fake the sexy Instagram like the
sexual ones not the not the ones that
just do DIY sombrero I feel like all the
DIY crafty people have it but the sexy
girls have dogs mmm that's a specific
niche of camgirl maybe I don't know to
trust they're really nice to trust Joe
he probably wants a lot more cameras
than me I will have done
back on this one I just feel like it's
mostly like associated with being an old
spinster like a crafty like I want to
dress up as Black Panther to this event
and start kicking people in the face do
you have any book no pets never heard a
pet no never had a pet I know what do we
never had a pet yeah I never had a pet
oh nice goldfish I mean my brother had a
fish my sister had a hamster that's it
Wow well by association you had you had
one man like that's true I didn't know
you lived in a home where there were
homes oh so are you one of those people
who are like no they're my friends and
you're like oh well I have lizard
friends and they live with me yeah but
they're not my parents
they're my family yeah yeah yeah sure
yeah I just feel like home feels so
empty without cats in it that's my life
I'm a pet quarter if I had the chance to
I will [ __ ] collect like oh that's
what I want to do I want to foster
kittens I just want it done and never
poos or Peas no I'm just saying like if
it was ever put in ethically possibly
ania taxidermy animal I want them to be
alive everything I love dogs whatever I
just I just hate picking up a dog's poop
and the fact that I own you and I have
to pick up your poop you piece of [ __ ] I
want a dog that looks like a puppy
forever but doesn't act like a puppy
that's why you get a chimpanzee and then
you can train the chimpanzee to do
housework there's those people that
train their cats to [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
oh yeah that's great there's like a
there's a kitty little petty little yeah
that's not weird that's evolution
chimpanzee can rip your face off though
but have you seen a chimpanzee in
overalls though pretty cool pretty hard
to not what they're smoking in here
I've talked about it many times yeah I
want a chimpanzee wearing overalls with
that spinny [ __ ] hand
I want a full-on chimp band I want an
entire band where all the monkeys are
holding instruments and doing whatever
music they do they don't even have to be
making me so they pretend to play right
there all honesty
wearing suits with instruments that's
and doing whatever they're gonna do he
doesn't I love this video
my favorite zoo animal is a chimpanzee
you want to create a dog without a
butthole how dare you
they look like furry babies like furry
toddlers
[Music]